Michael Santana streams League of
Legends to almost 20,000 viewers every
day.
He's on a self-motivated quest to
become the best AD carry in North America
He makes over 1.5
million dollars every year from the
comfort of his own living room, alongside
his trusty sidekicks small cat and
mellow.
He's a QTPie and this is his story.
Michael "Imaqtpie" Santana's
professional League of Legends career
started in 2011, right around the time
that the LCS was being formed. He was
recruited by William "Scarra" Li to join his
team Rock Solid as their starting AD
carry. Soon after they formed, the team
finished fourth at the National ESL
Premier League in 2011 and were picked
up by Dignitas. Dig's initial lineup
consisted of Voyboy in the top lane, Jatt
in the jungle, Scarra in the mid lane, and
Imaqtpie and Locust in the bot
lane. Their first event under the
Dignitas banner was a massive success as
they defeated Curse Gaming, CLG and Epik
Gamer to win IGN Premier League Season 3.
(Casting)
The win helped establish
Dig as a legitimate contender in North
American League of Legends. This was a
time when NA's competitive League of
Legends scene was a far cry from the
structured franchised League it is today.
To compete at the highest level teams
had to drop the rest of their
responsibilities and devote their lives
to the game in order to become relevant
and often unsuccessful trips to
tournaments were a net loss financially.
"So initially, it was really a gamble. Because a lot of us were doing it out of passion and there almost no
revenue streams. So there was a point in time, where it cost more to travel to Cologne, for ESL's events
then it did to win third place. So you had to place second or first, to actually get your money back
for travelling like all the way from North America to Cologne."
So when Dig bowed out of IEM New
York's 2012 group stage, it was a big
deal.
(Casting)
Dignitas saw season
2 as an opportunity to become a force in
the scene. They placed third at IEM Kiev
which helped them qualify for the IEM
6 World Championship where they lost
to Moscow5 in the finals.
QTs performance in Kiev was
impressive, posting a 4.17
KDA while averaging 4.88
kills per game throughout the tournament
(Casting)
Aside from imaqtpie's stable
presence in the bot lane, Team Dignitas'
roster was a bit of a revolving door.
Jatt stepped down late in 2011 and was
replaced with Iwilldominate early in
2012. Crumbzz was picked up to fill the
hole left in the top lane by Voyboy's
departure. Throughout his career
Imaqtpie was one of the only
members of Dignitas that wasn't in and
out of the lineup and acted as a
stabilizing presence for a lineup that
was constantly in flux. Team Dignitas
were still finding themselves as a team
at the end of Season 2 and into 2013.
Iwilldominate left and Crumbzz went
back to the jungle while KiWiKiD was
signed on to be the team's new top laner.
That core along with qtpie would
eventually become the team's backbone
ahead of the North American LCS' inaugural season.
"Season 3 for me is the first step that Riot takes to make this game be like a real sport.
And so there will be a lot of eyes on this first season."
The creation of the North American
League of Legends Championship Series
saw eight teams from the region compete
in a structured league that was loosely
modeled off of traditional sports
leagues. "Ladies and gentlemen today is
the day, the official start of the League
of Legends Championship Series. This is a
groundbreaking moment in League history
as eight North American teams take their
first steps on the way to the Summoner's
Cup." For qtpie the NA LCS was a
chance to prove himself
among the region's best players every
week. In the beginning the LCS didn't
have an identity and each of the eight
participating teams were quite different
from one another.
You had the likes of Counter Logic
Gaming and Team SoloMid, established
organizations that had amassed massive
fan bases and teams like Vulcan who were
new to the scene and looking
make a name for themselves. And then
there was Dignitas, who were somewhere in
the middle
sometimes goofing around.
sometimes wowing on stage.
(Casting)
Dignitas were the LCS team that most
resembled a bunch of friends who were
just hanging out and playing League of
Legends at an extremely high level.
(Casting)
Dignitas started their LCS run with a
whopping 16 and 5 record in their first
21 games of the spring split and qtpie
proved that he was a top-tier
North American AD carry. He was the
second in the league in KDA behind
Sneaky and his CS average was second
only to Doublelift. Dig stumbled at the
end of the season going 1-6 in their
final seven games to finish the season
with a 17-11 overall record.
(Casting)
They were then immediately booted from the
playoffs by Good Game University.
(Casting)
The team's volatility continued into the summer split where they started
the Season 6-2 but finished 13-15, narrowly avoiding relegation. Heading into the 2014 season
KiWiKiD moved from top lane to support
and the team signed CruzerTheBruzer.
This move marked an important moment in
Imaqtpie's career and was the peak
of qt's competitive prowess as a North
American AD carry
"I mean as bad as it is to say I'm never worried about any team,
like I know if I just like play my game I'm better than them."
(Casting)
At this time Dignitas was actually looking to
get rid of Kiwi from the roster entirely.
"The original plan was to just remove him
from the team completely but I'd
actually asked our manager to keep Kiwi
on the team to make him my support like
I took Kiwi from top lane barely playing
support into the support that he is now
and honestly I think he became a great
support."
2014 saw more of the same from
Dignitas. The team finished 12 and 16
during the season, placing fourth overall
The year was marred by roster shuffling
as both Shiphtur and Zionspartan
joined the team while Scarra popped in
and out of the lineup. Dignitas would
take 5th place in the playoffs.
"We've always had problems with the team, that have stopped us from being as good as we could be.
I honestly feel like, the people we have we could be the best. It's just our mentality is terrible."
It turns out when you're competing on a
national stage with four of your best
friends and everyone gets along
complacency can set in and it's that
complacency that imaqtpie it would
eventually capture as his on stream persona.
That's right, qtpie was able to make not giving a crap a full time,
dedicated and lucrative business.
But, professionally QT understood that the
LCS was going through a transition.
"I wasn't meshing well with the scene, with where it was going.
Because, when I got into League it was completely different than how it is now."
More money was flowing into the league
and the pressure for teams to perform
was greater than ever.
Organizations began to tinker with their
rosters in search of more wins, breaking
up their stalwart players in favor of
super teams. This is something qt
quickly realized he couldn't be a part
of. If he couldn't play with his friends
he couldn't play in the LCS.
"I love this team, I f***ing couldn't stand it if we got anyone else or if I was on another team.
Jesus Christ, f***cking people. Like, this team's great, I love 'em.
That's why I want this to work."
In October 2014
imaqtpie announced that he would
not be re-signing with Dignitas.
"So for me League has always been something that's just super fun.
I am competitive by nature definitely, and I always strive to do my best to win.
But I never had it in me to cut players for underperforming and things like that."
QT knew he still had the competitive
drive to play, so he took that drive and
put it towards his stream. Since making
the jump from the LCS stage to his
living room chair QT has embraced
the lackadaisical attitude he
criticized Dignitas for and adopted it
into his personal streaming brand. He was
always known for his charismatic
approach to the game even on-stage and
now he's turned that attitude into a day
job. Watching QT stream is an 8 hour long
amalgamation of professionalism.
and self-deprecating humor.
He pulls your emotions in two
directions. First he reels you in with
his staggering streaming consistency,
huge viewership numbers and high
soloqueue skill level. Then he keeps you
coming back for his random tantrum like
outbursts and fun first approach to
playing League of Legends.
QT takes every classic nerd stereotype and
wields them as a means to his success.
His ungroomed aesthetic and everyday
outfit of basketball shorts and a white
tee make him look more like the person
your parents warned you you'd become if
you didn't give up gaming than a
millionaire.
What's most interesting is how self-aware he is about all of this. What best exemplifies this is his
ongoing virtual feud with Team Liquid's
Doublelift.
QT has routinely flamed NA's most famous pro AD carry, challenged him and claimed that he is
the superior player.
"Do I have a retort? I have no idea what to say, I shit on Qtpie every time I see him in soloqueue.
This David versus Goliath style
feud shows just how relevant QT is to
the League of Legends community. The joke
has reached as far as the LCS stage and
stoked the fires of Twitch chat
whenever Doublelift competes.
"I've heard some rumors going around that the real reason that you're back in the NA LCS
Is to avoid running into Qtpie in soloqueue. Can you provide with whether or not there's any truth to that."
"Dude, I was ranked higher than Qtpie for like five months, and the one time he's higher rank than me
he like has to rub it in my face.
But, no. Qtpie is boosted garbage."
Even four years after his last LCS game, QT's
popularity still rivals some of the
game's best.
It's been almost four years since imaqtpie left Dignitas. In that time
he's accrued more viewership on Twitch
than any other League of Legends
streamer. He streams to almost 20,000
viewers each day around 50 hours a week
and has more than 2 million followers. QT
did make a short return to the rift in
professional League of Legends with
Delta Fox in the summer of 2017. The team
was comprised of five notable streaming
personalities and competed in the NA
Challenger series as a subsidiary of LCS
team Echo Fox. Imaqtpie, Scarra,
Dyrus, Voyboy and shiphtur made up a team
full of old guard LCS pros who were
apparently taking this project seriously.
"Look you cannot argue that the talent of those players."
"Uh, in the past has been some of the best players in the game. Now coming back together to dust off their
their competitive skills."
"That was the first thing that came with ease for them of the competitive side was wanting to win."
"And the record may not show it, but I have to think that across the board it has reignited their competitive fires."
Unfortunately the meme stream
dream team as they called themselves
didn't secure a game win during the
entire split they competed in Challenger.
It definitely didn't help that they
fielded a team with three players who
were primarily mid laners. All their
games were fairly similar each player
would often win their lane and then
Delta Fox would just get buried by their
opponents superior teamwork in a lot of
ways the Delta Fox experiment was
quintessential qtpie, they were a
team of solid players but they didn't
treat the team seriously enough to even
win a single game. Just as soon as it
started the Delta Fox experiment
finished in winless fashion. It was back
to the day-to-day streaming grind for QT
and his loyal subscribers. He's arguably
more famous than some of the best LCS
players in the world, commands more
attention and lives a more relaxed
lifestyle. QT's popularity shows the
breadth of the esports community and how
game adjacent personalities like him can
flourish with the right brand, tone and
work ethic which is the ever constant
paradigm with QT. He's a hard-working
self-made millionaire whose primary
means of making money is acting like he
doesn't care about anything but having
fun all day long.
According to a March 2017 article
from Rolling Stone Imaqtpie
streaming career generates more than 2
million dollars per year in revenue. All
that said the pro lifestyle has changed
a lot since QT's Dignitas days. We've
surpassed the era where a team could
attend a tournament and come home losing
money. In the new franchised iteration of
the NA LCS many pro players make a
livable wage and they're surrounded by
staff whose job it is to take care of
them and their health. Imaqtpie
left the Wild West of the early days of
League of Legends for the comfort of his
living room gaming setup and a whole lot
of money.
But since his departure the Wild
West has undergone a major facelift
which begs the question did Qtpie
leave some potential out on the rift?
QT was even dethroned from his hard
lock at the top of League of Legends
independent streaming charts. Tyler1
has been unbanned from the game and has
made waves in his return to streaming. On
January 8th Tyler1 dismantled Faker's
all-time individual League of Legends
streaming record with more than
380,000 concurrent
viewers
He finished the month with more
viewership than QT.
Maybe QT could have continued playing
pro and dominated LCS bot lanes like he
always wanted but his transition to
streaming has definitely worked out well
for him. The only thing we know for sure
is that whatever choice was wisest QT
doesn't care.
"Bye!"